um one more clip from julian edelman as
it relates to the patriots left behind
the quarterback question now that the
patriots have drafted mac jones in round
one and they have cam newton how is it
going to work everyone wants to know
that here's edelman's thoughts on the
quarterback scenario in his appearance
on the michael irvin podcast
last year was an absolute like joke
which it was i mean
you know these these the covid stuff i
mean you can you couldn't have a routine
there was like so many
regulations and spacing and trackers i
don't think it was fair to see
um
you know with with how cam had to go
through that you know what i mean and
i'm going to be very interested to see
how he goes this year because he's got
now he's got a year under his belt
my guy's probably working his tail off
on all his reads
you know he's he's probably been working
hard that's that's his mo kim works hard
you know now we gotta we gotta see if he
can work smart in the right areas and if
he does that he's gonna give himself an
opportunity to do well you know what i
mean you know but he's also gonna have
to beat out the young gun
because the young gun is there a little
mac attack whatever you know this this
kid you know you know
that's a that's a
a first round draft pick that's like a
real first round draft pick
yeah that's a first round draft pick
that
people still believe kyle shanahan
intended to take with the third overall
pick after the 49ers trade up and
changed his mind or had his mind changed
for him directly or indirectly to go
with trey lance instead so
this is going to be a challenge for cam
newton but everything i've heard is the
patriots love cam newton and work hard
versus work smart maybe by year two he
has a better idea of where he needs to
direct his efforts
to get to be the guy
that he can be in new england offense
but but that's a revealing comment
working hard versus working smart
because
hey
you can spin your wheels all day long
hey you worked really hard but what did
you accomplish what did you do to make
yourself better and i think that's going
to be one of the key aspects for year
two for cam newton figuring out where he
needs to put in that effort in order to
be the right quarterback for the new
england offense because if he's not
they got mac jones shireen
yeah pressure's on cam newton no
question about it and we forget
sometimes
mike that we're talking about a former
nfl mvp i mean he was mvp of the league
just in 2015 and now we're talking about
a guy who needs to work smarter as well
as as work harder so
you know i i did think it was revealing
and i would have liked to have delved
more into what he meant exactly by that
but he's going to have to
fight off mack jones because the
patriots are going to go with this guy
mack jones is ready to play and they're
going to go with him if if cam newton
struggles we know what they think of
jared stidham i think jared stinnum is
probably out the door now that they've
signed brian hoyer so the next guy up is
mac jones and he's going to be their
quarterback he's going to be the
president and the future the moment that
cam newton stumbles so he's going to
have to play much better in his second
season in new england in this offense
which they believe he can do but he's
going to have to do it and he's gonna
have to get it done relatively quickly
during the season if they go on some
kind of losing streak i think you're
gonna see mac jones pretty quick
and you know what
even though stidham
arguably would be the guy
that you would trust more
if he had to play remember brian hoyer
screw up last year against the chiefs in
the monday night game that that cam
didn't play but
if you're talking about grooming
the young player
hoyers the guy
to help groom
the young player he's the guy to help
teach mac jones everything he needs to
know so he can take over for cam newton
sooner rather than later and you see the
points bad odds there cam newton the
favor to take the first snap at minus
275 but the over under on mac jones
taking over i think tom curran told us
on pft pm a few weeks ago that
i think his over under was like eight or
nine games for mack jones to start i
think i'm not sure i think uh but uh i
hey i i think we're gonna see mack jones
at some point this year
because we saw
cam newton get yanked a couple of times
last year bill belichick's not bashful
about taking out his quarterback and
putting in another guy if he thinks it's
going to help make a difference for the
team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports